bonjour ayant pas dit bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous rejoindre l'invité
politique ça va tanguer député du lot
secrétaire général des républicains on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour stéphane
bern est bon jour qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france
on va parler pour commencer de ce qui se
passe chez les républicains je le disais
ça y est c'est officiel on connaît les
six candidats en lice pour le congrès y
avait il y avait peu de suspense mais ça
a été rendue officielle lire d'abord un
mot de ce qui se passe du côté de lui
des puisqu'on a appris hier que lui dit
présenterait son propre candidat à la
présidentielle soit le choix sera fait
le 27 novembre prochain c'est ce qu'a
annoncé le parti quelle est votre
réaction est ce que c'est un échec pour
les as l'air est ce que c'est un échec
pour lyon la droite et du centre non en
gardons notre calme et notre sérénité le
chemin qui nous amène jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle est un long chemin et
dans ce chemin là il est naturel normal
compréhensible tactique que chaque parti
se fasse en novembre montrent qu'il
existe et donc potentiellement désigné
candidat est ce que pour autant tous ces
candidats ont vocation à aller jusqu'au
moment fatidique de l'élection
présidentielle la réponse est non et si
on se parle franchement l'histoire
politique des pré présidentielle elle
est faite de candidats qui finalement
n'ont pas été candidat à l'élection
présidentielle on est à un moment où
chacun se compte c'est légitime que lui
dit le fasse comme les autres partis
politiques et la garde ça devrait être
lui jean-christophe lagarde c'est le
présent du dolby il n'ira pas jusqu'au
bout c'est à dire sa joie il cherche à
peser auprès de votre famille politique
je ne sais pas s'il ya bout ou pas et
c'est à lui de le dire et je le dis avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de respect à
l'égard de ceux qui domaine devront être
nos partenaires politiques mais ce que
je sais c'est que le chemin est très
long d'ici l'élection prison il faut
juste pas de jugement définitif il ya
quelques semaines on disait que vous
avez bertrand ne participerez par la
primaire que c'était fini qu'on était
morts qu on était cuit enfin bref
aujourd'hui tout le monde rentre dans le
même système de départage voyez chaque
jour nous réserve de bonnes surprises
depuis quelques temps et c'est une bonne
nouvelle alors heureusement que les tous
les candidats auto déclarée n'iront pas
au bout parce qu'il n'y a plus d'une
trentaine quand même à ce jour ça risque
de faire un peu beaucoup au premier tour
la présidentielle à l'étranger ne sont
pas chez les républicains non mais alors
le si jean christophe lagarde ou si les
républicains ainsi l'élu dit pardon
décide de présenter son propre candidat
est ce que c'est pas aussi la
conséquence du fait que votre processus
de départage a exclu des facto les
centristes non si c'est une décision qui
a été prise qui n'exclut parce que la
décision nous avons pris ces centristes
bas sinon parce que il faut se souvenir
qu elles étaient 6 avant de participer
il n'aurait peut-être pas présente et
qu'elle gagne il n'était pas question
qui présente quelques uns vous allez
dans les derniers mois en fait vous avez
plus de recul politique que moi vous
savez comme moi que il y a eu une vie
politique avant la primaire avant la
primaire comment faisons-nous avant la
primaire ont désigné notre candidat au
congrès comme nous allons faire là c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui nous avait permis de
gagner pour ce qui est de jacques chirac
et de nicolas sarkozy en 2007 et ensuite
il ya des discussions qui s'engage entre
les différents candidats pour que le
moment venu avant l'élection
présidentielle il y ait des ententes qui
puisse se faire sur un projet politique
pas sûr la bonne gueule de l'un ou de
l'autre et c'est ce qui s'est toujours
fait mais c'est ce que vous voulez faire
récuser cette année aussi mais avec lui
comme avec les autres le défi du
candidat des républicains qui sortira du
congrès le 4 décembre c'est pas de
s'arrêter en chemin le défi du candidat
des républicains il commence le 4
décembre au soir et il commence pas
seulement avec les adhérents et commence
avec les français et du 4 décembre
jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle
le défi de notre candidat sera de
rassembler les français pour former
demain une majorité le 4 décembre pour
commencer c'est pas un peu tard par
rapport aux autres non parce que dans le
calendrier historique dont je vous
parlais à l'instant c'est à peu près à
ce moment là que ça s'est toujours fait
et puis moi je crois que la politique
c'est aussi une affaire de sérénité je
pense que la sérénité le calme le fait
de ne pas céder aux pressions de
calendrier des uns ou des autres c'est
aussi un message politique que nous
adressons aux français la grande famille
des républicains
ce n'est pas une famille qui a peur des
circonstances où qu'ils changent d'avis
en fonction des semaines des sondages ou
ou de la conjoncture nous avons fixé ce
que la mariée depuis le début nous nous
y tenons si on veut demain présider la
france il faut déjà être capable d'avoir
la sérénité dans les temps de campagne
électorale et je pense que c'est un
message de solidité en jeu que je
comprends votre sérénité mais il ya
quand même un il ya quand même un
facteur qui s'est invité dans cette
campagne qui était pas qui était attendu
par personne c'est le facteur zemmour
parce que pendant que vous vous êtes
seringue vous vous donnez du temps pour
construire votre autre candidature lui
déroule son programme et il chasse sur
les terres non d'abord ils déroulent pas
son programme il déroule son agitation
sa provocation mais j'ai pas vu le début
du commencement d'un programme chez eric
zemmour à part peut-être
il cristallise toute l'attention
médiatique
oui l'onf il cristallise l'attention
médiatique est ce qui cristallise
l'attention des français je pense que
non et je pense qu'il ya l'écart
colossal entre l'excitation que le
microcosme médiatique peut avoir à son
égard et la réalité de la tension qui
lançait
des sondages à cette époque là alors que
eric zemmour n'a encore rien dit tous
annoncent qu'ils n'en sait rien de ce
qu'il va faire de ceux du pays s'il
devenait président de la république ça
ne veut absolument rien dire c'est un
fantasme eric zemmour est d'ailleurs
comme tous les fantasmes
fantasia personnes que
je n'ai croisé je vous le dis très très
sincèrement je n'ai pas croisé un
français pas croisé un électeur
avant-hier à marseille où se tenait une
réunion publique qui médit on espère que
cet individu devienne le président de la
république française je n'ai pas croisé
un français qui ne soit pas lucide sur
le fait qu' eric zemmour était là pour
fracturer la société le rôle d'un
président de la république
pas seulement pour fracturer la société
le rôle d'un président de la république
c'est de rassembler les français je n'ai
pas croisé un français qui est en lice
eric zemmour deviennent vraiment
président de la république en revanche
j'ai croisé des français qui nous disait
il faut que la parole politique devienne
plus franches il faut que vous disiez
d'avantagé chose vous vous les fassiez
aussi il faut que désormais vous donner
du sens à ce que vous faites que vous
soyez de droite ou de gauche on en
finisse avec cette espèce de de deux
grosses bouillabaisse dans laquelle on
n'est ni de droite ni de gauche et de
droite et de gauche c'est ça le message
qui nous est adressé je ne relativise
pas le fait que eric zemmour par eric
zemmour les français nous adresse ce
message mais senna et elle répond à ce
qu'ils répondent à des normes blême il
ne répond pas les français ont
l'impression
est ce que surtout et l'album hell
aborde des thèmes qui ne sont plus
abordé aujourd'hui non non il il est une
boîte aux lettres pour les français
c'est une manière pour les français est
objectivement je peux les comprendre et
houlette de quoi c'est une façon de deux
équipes manifestation une colère rien de
dire aux récents projets politiques on a
envie de vous faire confiance on a envie
de croire en la politique mais ce coup
et vous secouez vous s'échanger les
sondages avec 17% d'intentions pour
l'afrique sont vaincus je suis convaincu
que c'est le profond message est une
façon de vous bousculer en fait se
situer dans leur a donné les légitimes -
je suis citoyen avant d'être
responsables politiques et ça m'arrive
aussi d'avoir envie de bousculer la
classe politique mais vous n'avez
vraiment pas peur qui vous piquent des
électeurs des militants des cadres moi
je je ne raisonne pas on part de marché
électoral voilà pour se piquer des
électeurs non c'est pas les électeurs
c'est pas des boîtes de conserves qu'on
soit présent gère deux mondes et deux
voies pour gagner on a parlé aux
français ce qui fera la différence c'est
que la droite républicaine soit capable
de rassembler les français tous les
français des classes populaires aux
classes les plus aisées c6 et moi il ya
quand même un risque de fracture non non
il n'y a pas de risque de fracture
d'abord je le redis plus on va
s'approcher de la réalité de ce qu'est
eric zemmour - les français auront envie
de lui faire confiance mais je veux le
faire avec beaucoup de détermination
et reese et m'ont étonné imposteur
d'abord c'était une grosse erreur
intellectuelle j'ose le dire je pense
qu'on lui fait grief aujourd'hui de
beaucoup de solidité intellectuelle
qu'il n'a pas des gains de
penseurs comme eric zemmour est capable
de dire qu'il est philosophiquement
contre la peine de mort cette phrase-là
écrite par un lycéen au bac de français
elle prend 2 sur 20 parce que cette
phrase-là philosophiquement pour la
peine de mort ça veut rien dire c'est
juste b c'est juste idiot c'est juste
intellectuellement pas tenable et donc
je trouve que ont fait beaucoup mousser
une espèce de splendeur autour des
risées moment je n'ai aucun complexe
intellectuelle d'infériorité à son égard
il a fait beaucoup plus d'études que moi
il est sûrement beaucoup plus brillant
sur bien des sujets mais je n'ai aucun
problème à dire que quand il dit une
bêtise c'est une bêtise et je vais
au-delà sur bien des sujets j'ai des
accords qui sont majeurs en jeu combat
cette forme de relativité des choses
qu'un d'eric zemmour explique
aujourd'hui que le maréchal pétain a
sauvé les juifs français c'est pas un
détail ses principales dans sa pensée
c'est pas secondaire et donc pour moi je
commence par cela et je ne peux pas
écouter le reste de ce qu'il dit sur les
questions migratoires sur les questions
républicaine parce qu'il commence par
dire cela qui est pour moi et
disqualifiants et je veux le dire à nos
concitoyens qui nous écoutent attention
à ne pas tout relativiser moi je dis
abolisse par eric zemmour il a le droit
de dire ce qu'il veut de penser ce qu'il
veut aucun problème pour que nous
débattions les uns les autres avec lui
ou contre lui mais je dis simplement
qu'il faut que désormais nous
considérions qu'il ya des choses qui
sont disqualifiante disqualifiant
pourquoi je serai bien prédit est ce que
ça veut dire qu'il n'est pas dans le
champ républicain examen est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il n'a pas sa place dans la
course à la présidentielle il a sa place
dans la course à la présidentielle ce
n'est pas le propos moi je ne vais pas
de chasse aux sorcières je dis
simplement que quand on est capable
aujourd'hui de dire que philippe pétain
a sauvé les juifs français que l'on
oublie que les lois juives puisqu'on les
appeler comme ça on été annoté de la
main de philippe pétain ont été
renforcés de la main de philippe pétain
qu'on a fait retirer la nationalité
française aux juifs pour pouvoir les
livres et plus facilement et tout cela à
la demande personnelle de philippe
pétain lorsque qui que ce soit eric
zemmour un autre conteste cette réalité
là il est au mieux profondément
malhonnête au pire totalement
incompétents historiquement et je n'ai
aucun problème à le dire clairement on
va revenir à votre congrès aurélien
pradié cette décision de bertrand elle
vous a surpris cette décision participe
au congrès vous à soulager vous vous y
attendiez soulagé je suis sûrement parce
que c'est quand même beaucoup plus
simple quand tout le monde accepte la
même règle du jeu surprise je suis pas
assez intime de xavier bertrand pour
vous dire qu'elle met surprises en tous
les cas je pense que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour tout le monde y compris
pour les autres candidats de voir que
désormais notre famille politique est
organisé pour que le 4 décembre vous
ayez un nous ayons un candidat commun et
c'est très bien pour tout le monde pour
xavier bertrand comme pour les autres
candidats est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour lui xavier bertrand est ce
qu'il prend pas un risque en se
présentant en fait que les militants par
exemple lui reproche d'avoir quitté les
républicains ne pas avoir voulu jouer le
jeu d'avoir eu quelquefois plusieurs
déclarations à l'emporte-pièce et qu'il
me fasse payer au moment du vote en
choisissant quelqu'un d'autre est-ce
qu'il prend un risque oui mais on ne
venait pas président de la république si
vous empruntez un jour pris un risque et
même parfois plusieurs et d'ailleurs je
trouve que ça se respecte la prise de
risque en politique est assez courageux
au fond c'est également moins
défendables chrono à l'issue du congrès
c'est quoi je pas de pronostic je dis
c'est manque aujourd'hui rien n'est fait
et je dis que voulait rencontrer les
militants vont faire un peu sentir et je
sens que rien n'est fait je sens qu'ils
sont en attente de la part de tous les
candidats et vous pouvez avoir un choix
par exemple j'aurais un choix parce que
je suis militaire
par exemple damien abad soutien à xavier
bertrand enfin il y avait fait le choix
de ne pas exprimer de position d'ici le
4 décembre pour une raison simple c'est
qu'on ne peut pas être avec le président
de notre parti christian jacob
organisateurs du système des partages et
prendre part mais ils sont en attente
vous dites les militants mais ils vont
trancher comment pourquoi vous faisait
des débats télé par exemple on est
choisi par un bon système pour
départager les convives on aura sûrement
des débats télé on va en discuter à tout
à l'heure j'y suis favorable à une
condition c'est que ce soit pas
l'organisation de la boucherie voilà
parce que je veux le dire à tous mes
collègues candidats pour qui j'ai
beaucoup de respect et c'est justement
parce que j'ai du respect que parfois je
suis un peu un peu casse pieds avec eux
tous les candidats que nous avons des
qualités tous tous ces candidats là il
mérite de faire entendre leurs idées et
j'ai beaucoup de respect d'amitié pour
chacun d'entre eux et je serai
extrêmement exigeants avec eux justement
parce que j'ai d'amitié du respect et je
leur dis que personne n'a intérêt à ce
qu'il y ait du sang sur les murs
personnes donc on peut organiser des
débats télévisés à une condition c'est
que soit pas l'occasion de se taper sur
la figure
un dernier mot après on va passer au
reste de l'actualité sur edouard
philippe cette fois-ci edouard philippe
attaqué ce matin dans le figaro par
christian jacob et edward qu'il est pas
mieux la france est ce que dit le
président du parti vous inquiète t elle
de voir filer parce que lui pour le coup
il va vous prendre des électeurs non il
ne m'inquiète pas parce que il est
le clone d' emmanuel macron du mois le
clown politique il a été son serviteur
politique donc je vois pas pourquoi les
français ne voulant plus des manuels
macron voudrait d'une pâle copie
parfaite vous dire qui a été son
collaborateur il a déjà commencer par
vous prendre les grands élus en fait on
sait pas très nouveau et si vous parlez
des classes moyennes que j'ai en tête il
ya quelques grands élus qui depuis trois
ans toutes les semaines comme les stars
toutes les semaines qui annoncent
qu'elles vont quitter l'as la scène nous
annoncent qu'elles vont rejoindre
emmanuel macron bon je considère que
quand on l'a dit 30 fois pour certaines
ces grands élus c'est que c'est pas une
grande surprise donc s'ils veulent y
aller qu'ils y aillent mais gagner
carnet d'autres non je ne suis pas très
inquiet je suis sincère il ya un certain
la droite qui voulait emmener ne veulent
pas qu'ils veulent pas rejoindre
emmanuel macron mais ce sera pour plus
facile pour eux entre guillemets de
rejoindre edouard philippe et bien c'est
qu'ils ont le sentiment de trahir la
cause ou c'est précisément ce que
j'allais vous dire
ce sont des lâches pire que les traîtres
ce sont des lâches parce que n'ayant pas
le courage de dire clairement qui le
soutiennent emmanuel macron ils
soutiennent son collaborateur edouard
philippe je trouve ça affreusement lâche
quitte à trahir autant de fer avec le
chef pas avec le sous-chef lui on va
passer le reste de l'actualité et ce qui
inquiète ce sont les prix les prix de
l'énergie les prix à la pompe aurélien
pradié qui augmente avec des niveaux
historiques l'essence est plus cher
qu'elle mettait au moment dé gilet jaune
le gouvernement étudie des mesures de
protection pour les français si les prix
des carburants devrait continuer à
augmenter dans la durée c'est ce qu'a
dit à gabriel attal l'issue du conseil
des ministres est ce que le gouvernement
prend les bonnes mesures pour vous il
faudra prendre des mesures d'urgence
parce que on a là une situation qui est
extrêmement inflammable pour nos
concitoyens les plus précaires les plus
fragiles est les plus modestes ceux qui
dans le lot ont besoin de leur voiture
pour aller faire du ménage comme aide à
domicile tous les jours pour eux c'est
une facture qui est aujourd'hui
insupportable mais derrière nous ne
couperons pas à un débat plus large sur
notre choix énergétiques on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'on ne peut pas se passer
du diesel pour un somme de déplacement
si on pouvait s'en passer on règlerait
pas les prix on éviterait de consommer
du diesel donc nos concitoyens qui
consomment lui disent elles aujourd'hui
à des niveaux de prix invraisemblable ne
font pas par plaisir ils le font par
nécessité
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut désormais
reposer le débat sur l'utilisation du
diesel pour les particuliers et cesser
avec ce discours politique facile qui
consiste à dire que le tout électrique
et et l'avenir mais ça te faut avoir le
courage politique de le dire par
ailleurs lé prix d'énergie sont les prix
de toutes les énergies qui pose problème
sur l'électricité sur le gaz les mesures
que le gouvernement a appris ce sont des
mesures dérisoires elles ne tiendront
pas sur la durée d'ailleurs elles ont
été nominés penser à quoi ou chèque
énergie par exemple pour le show et
bernard j au blocage du cfaa celle qui
nous a été annoncée aujourd'hui c'est
insuffisant évidemment l'histoire
d'ailleurs c'est tellement insuffisant
que même le premier ministre dit que ça
tiendra jusqu'au moment des
présidentielles et qu'après en gros le
suivant se débrouillera avec la faire et
là nous touchons à des sujets plus
fondamentaux et qui sont mouchoirs
énergétique est ce que nous voulons
vraiment aller vers le nucléaire
continuer à soutenir une industrie qui
est un fleuron pour notre pays moi je le
crois c'est aussi ce que pense le
président la république avec france 2030
oui après avoir dit la salle dérisoire
aux citoyens voire manifs et 30
milliards sur cinq ans sur différentes
filières moi je j'aime de moins en moins
écoutés je jamais beaucoup aimé
d'ailleurs écouter emmanuel macron mais
ce que j'aime pour regarder ce qu'il
fait il a commencé au début de son
quinquennat nous expliquent qu'ils ne
croyaient pas au nucléaire il a dit des
dizaines de fois dans les mêmes mises en
scène avec des grandes tribunes des
grands slogans etc il a ensuite fermer
fessenheim la centrale de fessenheim ça
c'est un acte c'est un petit acte c'est
un acte colossal
d'idées avec les écolos tandis le
politique qui qui a été payé sur le dos
de fessenheim est aujourd'hui vient nous
dire qu'il croit au nucléaire quoi il a
changé d'avis pour vous parce qu'il voit
bien que l'état de l'opinion a changé
d'avis il voit bien qu'on ne peut pas
faire autrement que d'aller vers le
nucléaire et je veux le dire avec un
discours environnemental je suis très
préoccupé par la question
environnementale je pense que ma
génération c'est un sujet presque
instinctif mais l'urgence aujourd'hui
environnementale c'est l'urgence
climatique c'est la consommation de
l'émission de co2 c'est ça la véritable
urgence pour sauver la biodiversité
sauver les milieux naturels et la
meilleure manière de limiter notre rôle
notre
production de co2 pardon c'est de passer
par le nucléaire je pense que c'est une
énergie qui est aussi stratégique pour
notre industrie notre économie pour le
portefeuille des français que pour
l'environnement je pense juste juste
pour revenir juste pour terminer avec
l'histoire de d'énergie prix à la pompe
c'est quoi la mère de la meilleure
mesure à prendre c'est un chèque essence
par exemple poussé intervenir sur les ip
flottante les deux vous feriez quoi vous
je pense qu'il faut qu'on intervienne
sur le système de taxation des
carburants l'échec je suis toujours très
très sceptique parce que d'abord ça dure
pas dans le temps que on a toujours des
trous dans la raquette et qu' on ne
touche pas tous les français il ya quand
même ans a quand même un problème
taxation peut être une bonne solution
provisoire il faudrait se poser la
question plus large il ya quand même un
problème c'est que le pays s'est
massivement endettés pendant la crise et
on nous a beaucoup dit qu'en fait
rembourser cette dette se se baserait
sur un retour de la croissance la
croissance elle est forte alors elle
revient mais si par exemple on supprime
on baissent très fortement les taxes sur
l'essence mais c'est pas de recettes
pour l'état donc la croissance et le
lancement de la croissance le soutien à
la croissance il passera plus par un
choc fiscal notamment sur les
entreprises que sur la question des
carburants là nous parlons de la
consommation des français et donc de
leur capacité de pouvoir d'achat c'est à
dire y compris de contribuer à la
relance économique l'autre actualité
c'est cette enseignante sa professeur
qui a été agressée dont son lycée
c'était vendredi dernier agressé par un
élève qui a été condamné il est jugé en
comparution immédiate condamné à cinq
mois de prison avec sursis c'est une
sanction à la hauteur pour vous je pense
qu'elle était à la hauteur si elle est
appliquée et si derrière il y a une
véritable concrétisation de la peine
d'abord moi je veux adresser à la fois à
cet enseignant d puis à l'ensemble de la
communauté enseignante messages de
soutien la république ne tiennent pas
sinon enseignants ne tiennent pas ça le
rôle des
enseignants je pense qu'elle ne les
soutient pas assez et qu'il nous faut
être absolument d'intransigeant parce
qu'en s'en prenant à une enseignante on
s'en prend à l'idée qu'on se fait de
l'autorité on s'en prend à une femme
mais on s'en prend aussi à l'idée qu'on
se fait de la république et la
transmission du savoir et c'est ça qui
est absolument insupportable et on ne
peut pas constater les faits divers
puisqu'on nous parlent quasiment de
faits divers à chaque fois
successivement sans se demander s'il
n'ya pas un problème systémique
aujourd'hui vous avez bon nombre de nos
enseignants qui enseigne la peur au
ventre alors qu'ils exercent un des plus
beaux métiers du monde et ça c'était
insupportable et c'était la
responsabilité aux responsables
politiques d'être à la hauteur à leurs
côtés un mot sur la crise sanitaire en
cours du coup ça a l'air d'aller mieux
du côté l'épidémie pourtant le
gouvernement demande à ce qu'une
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et éventuellement du pass
sanitaire jusqu'au 31 juillet comment
est-ce que vous interprétez cette mesure
je suis personnellement je n'engage pas
ma famille politique défavorable à la
prolongation de dupas sanitaires sur une
période aussi longue pour une raison
très simple c'est ça veut dire que vous
auriez été d'accord pour le prolonger
mais moins longtemps je pense que
jusqu'au quai no 15 novembre c'est ce
qui était prévu c'est le bon gars et je
pense qu'il ne faut pas aller au delà
jeu même si même s'il ya un risque de
reprise épidémie il y a toujours un
risque la vie elle est faite de risque
la vie politique elle est faite de
risque aussi et la vie sanitaire elle
est faite de risque est ce que pour
autant il nous faut abandonner
l'essentiel de ce qui fait notre vie
démocratique la liberté de nos
concitoyens ma réponse est non et la
main du législateur elle doit trembler à
chaque fois qu'il s'est agi d'aller vers
la facilité la facilité c'est la
prolongation du passani terre la
difficulté c'est l' équilibre entre nos
libertés individuelles et la
responsabilité sanitaires et je pense
que cet équilibre la commande de
s'arrêter au 13 novembre et de retrouver
les outils si nécessaire lorsque la
crise pourrait reprendre ce qui a priori
n'est pas le cas et comme le pire n'est
jamais sûr on doit pouvoir aussi
desserrer les règles y compris sur le
passage du ter un doigt sur un autre
sujet que christophe castaner veut
remettre sur la table c'est la
prolongation du délai des ivg de douze à
quatorze semaines emmanuel macron dit
qu'il doit y avoir un débat à
l'assemblée manuellement comme
christophe castaner dit qu'il doit y
avoir un débat à l'assemblée avant fin
novembre vous êtes favorable ou à ce
débat est ce que au débat oui je suis
toujours favorable au débat c'est un
sujet extrêmement difficile je n'ai pas
d'avis arrêté à ce stade je le dis très
librement
je suis partagé entre deux obsessions la
première c'est de protéger les femmes
je reprends la phrase de simone veil
personne ne recourt à l'avortement
par par plaisir et donc il faut que nous
ayons toujours conscience de cela et en
même temps je pense que dans notre pays
nous avons un vrai besoin d'explications
de prévention pour que justement le
moins de femmes possible n'est besoin de
passer par cette disposition là qui est
douloureuse affreusement douloureuse
dans la vie d'une femme donc le débat il
sera positif je m'interroge us sur le
les priorités de christophe castaner
c'est assez terrible on a eu la semaine
dernière un débat sur la question du
handicap et nous a dit ce n'était pas
une urgence qu'il fallait attendre
tout ça je pense que c'est de
l'agitation plus politique plus que de
l'intérêt général sur cette question du
handicap je laisse la dernière question
à ses fans mais sur cette question du
handicap il ya un débat sur l'allocation
adulte handicapé notamment dont vous
voulez changer le mode de calcul le
débat a eu lieu également ici au sénat
cette semaine le gouvernement s'y oppose
en fait il est question d'individualiser
cette allocation pour que la personne
handicapée ne dépend pas des revenus de
son conjoint le gouvernement s'y oppose
x et une remise en cause du modèle
social vous pensez qu'il peut encore y
avoir un accord entre députés et
sénateurs ou vous pensez que c'est la
fin bon nul en eux on ne lâchera pas le
gouvernement sur ce sujet parce que il
ne l'est manifestement but et est
incapable de comprendre que ce sujet
était un sujet de dignité fondamentale
au fond c'est donc aux citoyens
comprennent bien c'est comme si mes
revenus vos revenus étaient
conditionnées aux revenus de nos
conjoints serait inimaginable
c'est comme si pour ma conjointe selon
son niveau de salaire le mien diminuerez
et pour votre conjoint ne l'avait pas
dire tout ça n'a pas de sens et donc ça
ne remet pas en cause notre système
social
c'est aujourd'hui la conjugale isation
l'allocation adulte handicapé qui remet
en cause les principes fondamentaux de
la dignité notamment pour les personnes
en situation d'handicap pour répondre
plus précisément à votre question le
débat va revenir à l'assemblée nationale
dans quelques semaines dans le cadre de
la niche parlementaire des communistes
c'est d'ailleurs un des rares sujets sur
lesquels tous les groupes politiques
auront réussi à se mettre d'accord et a
successivement remettre la bataille en
leur nom sur la table de l'assemblée et
du sénat donc je n'ai pas désespérer sur
cette question là le sénat a voté un
assouplissement du cumul des mandats
hier est ce que j'aimerais connaître
votre position là dessus j'ai été maire
avant d'être d'être député maire d'une
commune de mille et quelques habitants
je suis assez convaincu que si
l'assemblée nationale était peuplé d'un
peu plus de députés qui lorsqu'ils
rentrent le jeudi en circonscription
avait à s'occuper des affaires d'une
commune de 1000 habitants l'assemblée
nationale prendrait des décisions un peu
plus constructive et proche de nos
concitoyens l'occupante zelda wii avec
des limites parce que parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu un malentendu dès le départ
finalement ce que les français demandent
et c'était plus un cubain non plus les
rémunérations est bien vrai plafonnement
des années aucun cumul des mandats ni té
nous sommes d'accord d'ailleurs rapatrié
a aucune raison de cumul des indemnités
mais il n'y a pas de raison non plus
être député et maire de toulouse et
maire de marseille qui sont des
démissions au fond dames qui vous
prennent absolument tout votre semaine
en revanche être député et maire d'une
collectivité d'un nombre d'habitants je
pense que c'est positif pour la
démocratie merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]